j'accueille jacques chancel
n
comment thomas jacques rabia ça va quand
tu tombes dans une émission un petit peu
décousu allée des cous et elle est des
cons à recoudre bien alors jacques que
vous êtes aujourd'hui chroniqueur sur
france 2 et itélé mais aussi
administrateur de canal+ et conseiller
du président bertrand méheut
c'est vous qui lui avait conseillé de
virer car 0 à nouveau pas du tout pas du
tout de mer ça ne nous regarde pas ouais
nous avons un directeur général
directeur des programmes c'est à perdre
votre belle-mère et qui est l'autorité
pour faire ce qu'il a à faire de toute
manière il faut savoir une fois pour
toutes que les producteurs ou les
animateurs qui ont les émissions sur les
chaînes de télévision ne sont pas les
propriétés gagné la partie
et voilà alors avance à l'âge de 18 ans
j'ai été grand reporter à radio france
asie à saigon et puis toujours aux mains
de chine correspondant de guerre pour
match avant la télé avec le grand
échiquier sur antenne 2 et radioscopie
sur france inter voilà et puis lé livre
beaucoup de livres combien de livres
jusqu'à maintenant si on fait le compte
exact du bélier à 20h35 ac et paris-nord
nouveau même par rapport à qui et
certains chine au sein seraient d'accord
nicolas faille la boue alors le dernier
chez xo éditions s'appelle le prince ou
le festin des fous alors le pitch et
quatre hommes qui ont reçu un billet
d'avion pour saigon ils se connaissent
pas il ya feu bus le béarnais qui a
perdu femme et enfant dans un accident
de voiture
iago lee chin l'aristocrate russe exilé
aux usa et à sony de pour qui était un
solitaire agressif des faouzi qui est un
mystique adeptes de confucius alors ils
ont été choisis pour rejoindre le
royaume de rama dans le royaume de rama
ça se situe entre la thaïlande et le
cambodge
voilà et aussi pour prêter main forte au
prince contre la terrible société
secrète qui a décidé de renverser la
monarchie et de faire régner les
ténèbres vraiment roman moi j'ai voulu
écrire un roman des régions ouais un
roman d'aventurés partant d'un principe
que je rabâche le monde dans lequel je
suis ne me convient pas du tout mais je
le vis
i quand même avec une totale ivresse et
comme je suis assez lucide pour savoir
que le monde que je nous souhaite
nous ne leur ont jamais donc je la vente
par le royaume de ramasse une espèce de
pays de cocagne au règne le bon goût la
concorde
l'argent n'a plus cours toute vanité et
éradiquer les ambitions sont oubliées
enfin voila c'est un pays de rêve
oui un pays de rêve mais hélas que comme
dans tous les autres pays normaux ça
peut se casser la figure à la fin il n'y
a pas de vrai paradis hélas donc ces
quatre mousquetaires finiront par
découvrir une ville souterraine qui
concentrent sous ses voûtes la
quintessence de cet éden qu'est rama et
ils découvrent un temple d'or
j'ai eu la chance de vivre pendant six
mois dans les ruines encore avec
monsieur alors qu'ils étaient le
conservateur de l'école française
d'extrême orient d'ailleurs nom dans le
livre j'ai conservé son nom être étonné
parce qu'il vit encore
ouais et monsieur lors tous les matins
on allait se promener
on croisait un tout petit peu il y avait
des marchés on savait qu'un temple
allait s'ouvrir à quinze jours après on
revenait et c'est vrai qu'il y avait un
temple et un jour je lui avais dit ce
sont vraiment les plus belles merveilles
du monde
il m'avait répondu tu te trompe car en
thaïlande à la fonte à la thaïlande et
du cambodge
il y à mieux encore il ya surtout on a
les archives des cités souterraines mais
oleg on ne les dit couvrira jamais parce
que c'est la jungle c'est les entrées
les sorties ne sont pas répertoriés et
moi je me suis donné le bonheur le
plaisir de la découvrir et c'est ça
c'est ça le romancier c'est ça le
raconteur d'histoires et ce qui est
extraordinaire dans un roman les gholam
proprement c'est que sont les
personnages que vous autres l on connaît
à peu près le scénario 1 mais on ne sait
pas du tout ce que sera la fin alors
jacques quand même si c'est très barré
comme bouquin non je crois que là
vraiment on ne peut pas s'arrêter
lorsqu'on égal dans la rêverie le sol et
dans leur honneur le dans le fantastique
lorsqu'on est dans la création je crois
qu'il ne faut pas se donner de limites
un romancier pour moi ne se donnera lui
dire la vérité je me suis demandé si
vous n'aviez pas un peu fumé d'autres
pions homme avant de l'écrire
non et je veux vous dire lorsque nous
sommes arrivés tous en indochine
inception en tout cas pendant les trois
premiers mois après j'ai eu la
conscience véritablement d'aller voir
ailleurs mais nous y allions parce que
d'abord c'était les endroits merveilleux
des gens il fallait voir ce que c'était
sur le plan de la beauté du décor en
plus les pare-feu l'opium qui avait qui
avait une couleur tout à fait
exceptionnelle et les dames qui servait
locale bien sûr pour beaucoup d'ailleurs
de raziel fille de chinois et d'anglais
un cas très souvent le des femmes
sublimes dont il y avait tout un décor
et pour un pro garçon de 18 ans c'était
le plein bonheur alors dans votre
bouquin il ya beaucoup d'opium de toute
façon les gens fument beaucoup de
pionnier a beaucoup de rituel sexuel
aussi
et des fois les deux sont oui ça
l'ancien mec m'a nécessairement ouais
pas nécessairement c'est comme par
exemple à un jour quelqu'un me disait je
reviens du japon
j'ai eu une aventure extra extra
ordinaire avec une des chats j arrête de
free mais ça n'existe de le soir il faut
donc ya ces frimas les swings geisha est
une dame qui laisse le temps de vous
séduire qui j'ai la musique qui dort
jamais est un homme cola bhl ne lui fait
pas ce genre de choses là d'accord et la
respecte comme je vous respecte
voilà on est d'accord est loin du lycée
jacques chancel le pense le festin époux
c'est publié chez xo éditions mesdames
messieurs
alors j'ai une chance elle vous êtes
toujours très vert comme on peut le voir
ce soir je dis parfois j'ai été yeux
trop tôt je suis jeune trône en voilà on
voit bien